lawn crime daily special coverage of
Alec Murdoch's decision to sit on the
witness stand and tell his own story the
Senate Richard Alexander murdick wishes
to take the stand the double murder
suspect accused of killing his own wife
and son has been caught in Lies over and
over again
we're taking you through Thursday's
testimony with Murdoch sometimes angry
and other times very emotional did you
ever spend another night at Moselle
after June 7th never spend another night
at Mozelle why not
could
you don't want to
more on crime Deli covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everybody to Lone crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber Alec Murdock the man
already at the center of a double murder
trial in South Carolina was in the
spotlight Thursday
testifying in his own defense in front
of a full gallery and they Dove right
into the big question did he kill his
wife and son
on June 7th
2021 did you take this gun or any gun
like it
and shoot your son Paul in the chest in
the feed room at your property off
Moselle Road no I did not
Mr murder did you take this gun or any
gun like it
and blow your son's brains out on June
7th or any day or anytime
no I did not
Mr Murray
[Music]
did you take 300 Blackout
such as this
and fired into your wife Maggie's
leg torso or any part of her body no I
did not did you shoot a 300 Blackout
into her head causing her death
I didn't shoot my wife or my son any
time Mr murdick is that you
on the kennel video at 8 44 pm on June
7th the night Maddie Maggie and Paul
were murdered it is
were you in fact at the kennels at 8 44
pm on the night Maggie and Paul were
murdered I was
did you lie to sled agent oh and the
deputy Laura Rutland
on the night of June 7th
and told them that you stayed at the
house after dinner
I did lie to them did you lie to agent
Owen and agent Croft on the follow-up
interview on June 10th
that the last time you saw Maggie and
Paul was at dinner
I did lie to them
Alec why did you lie
okay to Owen agent Croft and Deputy
Rutland about the last time you saw
Maggie and Paul
as my addiction evolved over time
I would get any situations or
circumstances where I would get paranoid
thinking and it could be anything that
that triggered it might be a look
somebody gave me it might be a reaction
somebody had to something I did it might
be a policeman following me
in in a car
um
that night June 7th
after finding
Max and Paul Purple
don't talk to anybody without Danny with
you
all my partners were just repeatedly
telling me that
I had a deputy share taking gunshot
tests from my hands
I'm sitting in a
police car
with David Owen asking me about my
relationship with my wife and my son
and all those things
coupled together after finding them
coupled with my distrust for sled
caused me to have paranoid thoughts
normally
when these paranoid thoughts would hit
me I could take a deep breath real quick
just think about it reason my way
through it and just get past it really
quickly
I wasn't thinking clearly
I don't think I was capable of reason
and I lied about being down there
and I'm so sorry that I did
I'm sorry to my son buster
I'm sorry to Grandma Papa t
I'm sorry to both of our families
most of all
I'm sorry to Max
and Paw Paw
I would never
intentionally do anything
to hurt either one of them
ever
all right let me bring my co-host and my
legal analyst former defense attorney
Brian buckmeyer excuse me former defense
attorney Brian Brockman former trial
Attorney Terry Austin Brian I'll start
with you so Alec admits to lying and
those lies stem from the drug abuse the
jury gonna buy that
I'm not quite sure Jesse but but I think
what's going to happen is he does devise
they put on an expert to talk about
opioid abuse and how that can affect
someone's perception of reality and
whether or not they will tell the truth
or lie in difficult situations the
problem with that is it opens up
Pandora's Box because that paranoia can
also lead to violence violence could
lead to killing your wife and and son
and so it's really a dual edged sword
here you can give this explanation to
try to excuse why he made all these lies
and why the circumstantial evidence the
prosecution presenting doesn't line up
but if the prosecution is smart they can
also say yeah but are people who are
suffering from opioid abuse also very
violent quick to anger and also this
could be used against him all right
we'll see about that but I mean Terry
the defense directly asked about the
financial crimes is that the right move
here you know I think at the end of the
day it was the right move but I was
surprised look we know that judge Newman
LED in financial crimes we also know
that he didn't decide whether he could
be crossed on financial crimes so he
wanted to wait until the evidence came
in to see what happened if any door was
open but I think the defense decided
look let me just go straight at this
let's ask about the financial crimes you
can give your explanation it's going to
look better in front of the jury if you
explain what happened then if we tried
to hide this until you were
cross-examined so I think it was a good
strategy I'm not sure it worked though
we are going to talk more about this
there is a lot more to talk about this
because still ahead on Long crime daily
our coverage of the Alec murder trial
continues with more of his testimony he
tells us what it was like to find the
bodies of his wife and son on the
property mutilated from gunshot wounds
stay with us
[Music]
and welcome back to Long crime daily
everybody our coverage of the Alec
Murdoch murder trial continues now as
the defendant testifies in his own
defense defense attorney Jim Griffin
walked Murdoch through the night of the
murders and the discovery of the bodies
Murdoch was quite emotional as he
described calling 9-1-1 and trying to
help his youngest son Paul
I called 9-1-1
I was on the phone with 9-1-1
I was trying to tend to Maggie
and I just went back and forth between
them
where you um
going to Paul and Maggie while you're on
the phone with the 911 operators
yes okay yes
what did you do when you went up to Paul
at some point in time
hey Paul
was so
you're so bad
at some point
I know I mean I know I tried to check
him for a pot
um
I know I tried to turn him over
when you say you've tried to turn him
over but why were you trying to turn him
over
I don't know
I don't know I don't know why I tried to
try to move me and my boys laying face
down
and he's
done the way he's done it was the waves
it was
I could see you can see his brain laying
on the sidewalk
I didn't know what to do I mean that's
tried to turn him up he's got Grant him
by the belt one of the issues that
Murdoch's legal team brought up during
direct examination was the report that
the T-shirt Murdoch was wearing on the
night of the murders had high velocity
blood spatter on it now why is that
important well when Murdoch was indicted
for murder the lead investigator on the
case had told the grand jury that the
T-shirt was covered in blood he says he
didn't know until just a few months ago
that the shirt had actually tested
negative for human blood on
cross-examination sled agent David Owen
testified he didn't get an email
notification about the blood test from
the lab in photos from the testing you
can see the white shirt doesn't have
what appears to be any stains on it at
all other than the ones from testing
your chart was
went through testing and Analysis and
you were
part of this case provided results of
that were you not
yes sir
I mean I wouldn't provide it at the time
I've seen him
right getting
seen all these records
you um
but just let me ask you did you get on
your shirt
High Velocity blood spider from being
within a distance of a shooting mag near
Palm
there's no way that I had high velocity
blood spatter on me
had you seen reports that said that at
one point in time I have seen reports
that said that
just to be clear were you anywhere in
the vicinity when Paul and Maggie were
shot
I was nowhere near
Paul and Maggie when they got shot I'm
well aware that my clothes never became
an issue in this case until my lawyers
proved
that this blood spatter that they said I
had on my shirt from my wife and my son
was a lie
and that there was no blood on my shirt
and once they filed the documents and
they proved that that was a lie all of a
sudden the clothes I was wearing back on
that day became an issue
all right we also have a quick update
for you on a court Interruption earlier
this month remember when the Colleton
County Sheriff's Office had an issue of
a bomb threat well appears that they
have charged a man for calling in that
Bob threat deputies say Joey Coleman is
an inmate in South Carolina and they
believe he called the courthouse on
February 8th telling Steph that there
was a bomb in the judge's Chambers the
courthouse was evacuated while the 30s
authorities searched the building no
devices were ever found the Sheriff's
Office says there is no connection
between Coleman and Murdoch or the trial
Coleman is now facing felony charges for
the bomb threat and coming up on Long
crime daily we're bringing you more of
Murdoch's testimony as the defense meets
the question of financial impropriety
head on what Murdoch had to say about
accusations that he stole millions of
dollars from clients in his law firm and
what he says was the root of his
problems
[Music]
foreign
there were a lot of highlights in the
first half of Alec Murdoch's first day
on the stand and when Court resumed
after the lunch break there was
jaw-dropping testimony right out of the
gate the first half Murdoch's testimony
consisted of him walking through the day
his wife and son were shot to death and
he of course denied his involvement
explaining away various pieces of
evident pieces of evidence that were
hammered home by the prosecution but it
was quite a different story when his
attorney switched gears to Murdoch's
long list of alleged Financial crimes
check it out
Jerry's heard
about
testimony of you stealing client funds
did you do that I did
did you still
divert that Pharisee away from the law
firm I did
but don't worry don't worry Murdoch can
explain why and he did just that in the
next line of questioning
how did you get in such a financial
predicament
that led you to steal money that wasn't
yours
no I'm not quite sure how I let myself
get where I got but it came from
you know I battled that addiction for so
many years
I was spending so much money on
pills
I got in the spot I couldn't
now what type of addiction are you
referring to
my addiction is to is to
opiate painkillers and when specifically
oxycodone Oxycontin
oh and it didn't end there because last
but not least Murdoch addressed why he
hired Curtis Eddie Smith to kill him
after the murders also known as the
roadside shooting
did you ask him to shoot you as a
sympathy Ploy or did you want as a
sympathy boy yes sir why'd you ask him
to shoot you what was it what was the
end goal and you're that you wanted to
accomplish I meant for him to shoot me
so I'd be gone
all this was coming to a head I knew how
humiliating it was going to be for my
son
I mean I've been through so much
at the time in the bad place that I was
seemed like a better thing to do did you
have life insurance on you
oh yeah I had a lot of life insurance
how much life insurance did you have I
had 12 million dollars
he admitted all that
well long crime network is your home for
gavel to gavel coverage of the Alec
Murdoch murder trial you can watch live
streams from inside the courtroom here
expert Insight from legal professionals
and see information like timelines and
Exhibits it's all on lawncrime.com and
every day here on lawn crime daily we're
going to be right back with more
coverage of Alec Murdoch's testimony
[Music]
and welcome back everybody we put the
spotlight on Alec Murdoch's testimony in
the witness stand so we want to finish
off Today's Show by panning the camera
to the key players off the stand
starting with you our viewers we put up
a poll on our live stream on YouTube to
get your takeaways from day one and by
just the end of the day look at this 65
percent believe that Alec Murdock is
guilty 13 believe he's not guilty 14
believe that there's going to be a hung
jury eight percent undecided now the
second most crucial group of people are
the jury who will have a very important
decision to make when this is all over
and we can't forget of course Buster
Murdoch who's been watching his father
testify about his family member his
family's murders from the gallery and to
give us all of those key observations
from inside the courtroom long crimes
very own Gigi McKelvey and South
Carolina attorney Joe McCullough have
the scoop
they all were trying to subdue their
true feelings I'm sure they wanted to go
whoa but everybody was real composed
it's been really interesting to watch
this jury there are times where they
seem sympathetic there are times where
they seem like they're not buying it
it's really a mixed bag hard to read to
be honest but I've seen a little bit of
all emotions from that jury and then the
public of course lots of whispering
amongst each other and just give it I
can hear a lot of people's opinions from
behind he's looked down a lot during
this testimony face gets read I've
noticed his hands are touching his face
more a couple times he kind of puts his
head in his hand so it's really been
hard but at the end of the day whatever
he's feeling is definitely uncomfortable
or emotional just from what I can see
you know my view of the family
throughout this trial for five weeks
they have been largely impassive
dispassionate mask like and today I've
seen a motion from John Marvin
seen some emotion from uh Buster and he
wept from for at a point if he has the
angry resting face as someone called it
we don't know whether that's because
he's angry that his father is on trial
wrongly accused or whether he's angry
about something else
and they never know
and that's it right Terry because we can
never really know what a jury is
thinking even if you know if they appear
emotional they're looking down they're
engaged it's almost impossible to gauge
right oh it's absolutely impossible you
can only imagine what they must be
thinking though especially what they
were thinking about when Alec Murdock
was on that stand testifying on the one
hand he was very emotional Buster was
very emotional you might think to
yourself okay there are some jurors who
are feeling sympathy actually at one
point I actually felt some sympathy for
him but there might be many more jurors
who are thinking you know what this is
overacting I don't think you're an
attorney you shouldn't be that emotional
while you're on the stand so I think the
reaction to the jury could be very well
mixed but you know Jesse as we always
say only one juror needs to hold out and
you know we're going to get a Mr the
only thing I'll say about that is he is
talking about the death of his family so
that maybe could be a little different
now Brian from an attorney's point of
view what is jury engagement how does
that affect an attorney during a
cross-examination or direct well you
want to press on the issues that you see
the jury more engaged in and kind of
pull back on the ones that they're not I
know many of us were watching this
direct examination when Alec Murdock was
talking about Bubba and the chicken and
we were even joking we're like what is
he eventually going to say that Bubba
and the chicken did the murders like why
are we on this topic for so long but if
the jury is engaged if they're listening
if they're participating at least in
their body language or their facial
expressions to a test certain part of
testimony you keep going if you start
seeing them lose interest that's who you
want to maybe skip to the next chapter
in your cross or direct examination and
keep pressing forward so seeing the
engagement you can gauge who is for you
and who's against know your audience
bottom line Brian Terry thank you both
so much everyone out there thanks for
joining us here on Long crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
Justice in America
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]